what else we got another video was sent
in here that's a tick tock
a fight on spirit airlines let's go
uh-oh no
don't do that she trying to bring
somebody with him
two urban women and they like to fight
you know that and they're out here about
to get at it
there they go oh it's lit
it's lit it's lit
some fella got in a lot of hair pulling
a lot of ass a lot of thick ass being
see that whole charm
and there you go right there and this
kind of stuff i mean
uh this the kind of [ __ ] it's like
when does it end you know
why people can't figure out how to be
okay in society
you know and this is all too common
black people love to
fight in
kind of like outside the ring i feel
like
you know black people are not afraid to
fight anywhere that's really what i'm
saying
they'll fight wherever i think
other cultures mexican people they fight
more like in a car wash or in a boxing
ring
white people i think more fight like in
a courtroom
or sometimes outdoors like on a porch
but spirit airlines really has become
the bellator
of uh
of kind of like for the urban community
in the sky
it's become the bellator of the sky i
think that
um now i look i had to fly spirit one
time
god bless man and i saw two dogs go at
it
two people had dogs i don't know if this
was sanctioned or what but then [ __ ]
started throating at each other praise
god man so
just stay safe out there if you're on
spirit
i think just wear a jersey wear an
atlanta hawks jersey wear something that
kind of blends in you know uh
but know that
you could be near a scuffle i think
and that spirit bro amen that's spirit
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one